foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar combining
RNA scope technology with protein
detection a multi-omics approach using
RNA protein integrated code detection
workflow
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Leica biosystems
to learn more visit lycabiosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
with that I'd like to welcome our
speaker Blake mcalpin field application
scientists at Advanced cell Diagnostics
a brand of biotechnie Blake you may now
begin your presentation
my name is Blake mcalpin I'm a field
application scientist with Advanced cell
Diagnostics the company that brings you
RNA scope technology
I want to thank Leica for having me here
for this webinar
and today I'm going to talk to you about
combining RNA scope technology with
protein detection using the Leica Bond
so the title of my talk is combining RNA
scope technology with protein detection
a multiomics approach using RNA protein
integrated co-detection workflow
in this webinar I'll start with an
overview of the RNA scope-ish
technologies that we've developed at ACD
then we'll take a closer look at our
integrated code detection workflow for
RNA and protein detection using RNA
scope Technologies and with antibodies
I'll discuss the applications of this
technique as well as the workflow we'll
also look at how to analyze results from
our assays and then some common
challenges and how to troubleshoot them
finally I'll close by answering some of
your questions so there will be a live q
a at the end of this webinar and I'm
more than happy to answer the questions
that you place in the chat while I'm
giving this presentation
the key to this workflow is the order of
operations as I mentioned some epitopes
can be sensitive to the RNA scope-ish
procedures I'll get into this a little
more in detail but in this workflow we
are adding the primary antibody before
the RNA scope-ish
we also include a post primary fixation
to protect that Bond
after completing our RNA scope
pre-treatments hybridization and
detection we come back and add the
secondary antibody and detect our
protein targets
this approach enables a wide variety of
antibodies to compatible be compatible
with the RNA scope assays
some of you might be familiar with the
sequential code detection protocol we've
used in the past
in addition to the enhanced antibody
compatibility we've confirmed that icw
support supports mostly equivalent or
better performance of antibodies that
were compatible with the sequential
procedure and finally we've also tested
that the icw procedure maintains
equivalent ish sensitivity
and in this next table of summarize our
assays that are compatible with the icw
procedure that we're going to talk about
today on the left are the manual assays
which I'm not really going to talk about
today but they're here and on the right
are the compatible icw assays automated
on the bond RX so this includes our LS
red single Plex chromogenic assay the
multiplex fluorescent assay our base
scope assay which targets smaller RNA
transcripts and the micro RNA slope
assay which targets the smallest RNA
transcripts 17 to 50 nucleotides in
length
with code detection we use our TSA Vivid
dies so these are dyes produced by
Advanced cell Diagnostics which are
extremely bright and are compatible with
both protein and RNA scope
here we have a comparison of the
sequential workflow that I mentioned
earlier and this new integrated code
detection workflow that we're going to
discuss today
you can see the timing of the protease
digested is a huge difference between
the two workflows the addition of the
post primary fixation step protects the
primary antibody and the code detection
blocker step prevents cross detection of
the secondary antibody by the ish
chemistry
here we'll look at the impact of the icw
procedure on antibody performance we can
see good signal from the cd20 antibody
on a head of neck cancer tissue sample
using a green chromogen this is the IHC
only control so there's no RNA scope on
this slide
next we can see what happens to the
signal for this particular antibody if
it is applied after the RNA scope
pre-treatment steps so this would be
sequential RNA stop with ish and we can
see that a lot of the the antibody has
been degraded probably due to the
protease however
when we use integrated code detection
workflow we preserve the signal from
cd20 and we also have successful ppib
these little red dots RNA scope signal
in red
now I'm going to talk to you about a few
more examples in which iecw was used and
just show you kind of what it looks like
so here are a few examples of ish IHC
staining and breast cancer lung and
tonsil tissue so each of these uh use
the RNA scope red assay for ppib which
is essentially our housekeeping positive
control Gene and we can see the pairing
of the stating with CD3 cd8 or ki-67 IHC
staining CD3 and cd8 are two cell
markers
ki-67 is associated with proliferation
and tumor cell metastasis you can see
that the icw procedure preserves
antibody signal more effectively while
also introducing less background
compared to the sequential staining
I'll just give you a minute to look at
these
these are a few more examples of code
detection with IHC and
RNA scope in cervical cancer lung cancer
and lung cancer with ki-67
so we can see that there's a
compatibility with both green and brown
chromogens for the IHC staining
take a look at the icw with these red
ppib dots and the protein and compare it
to the sequential staining on the left
foreign
these are some images of fluorescent icw
so these are lung cancer tissues stained
with the fluorescent B2 assay and CD3 or
cd8 protein targets you can see after
the sequential staining the protein
Target was pretty degraded whereas when
completing it using our icw workflow the
protein Target seemed more preserved
here's an example of icw from a
publication from the Journal of
immunotherapy of cancer published in
this group is trying to understand the
cellular source of cytokines that led to
T Cell entry into the tumor
microenvironment because this can be a
rate limiting step in the effector phase
of the anti-tumor response
now cxcl10 is very difficult to identify
in tissues using antibodies but they
were able to use our Multiplex
fluorescent V2 kit to identify cxcl10
transcripts
then they used icw to identify cd45 and
Sox 10 positive cells with antibodies in
the same tissues they got very nice
staining and were able to quantify what
percentage of each of these cell types
were producing cxcl10 transcripts in
patients with different responses to
immunotherapy treatment it was very
interesting and clinically significant
study
oh
my last example comes from a paper
published recently in this journal of
Cell Biology this team of researchers
was investigating how the loss of tdp43
which is an important protein involved
in ALS frontotemporal dementia and other
diseases leads to disruption of
cholesterol metabolism and effects
myelination
here they used our icw kit with the
multiplex fluorescent B2 assay so they
could label oligodendocytes with gstp1
Amino fluorescence and assess the
related reduction of sreb F2 and ldlr
mRNA after CDP 43 had been deleted
they started with the RNA scope ish only
staining but the data was complicated to
interpret because of the other cells
expressing the markers they had
interested in
therefore they had to incorporate the
gstp1 amino fluorescence to be able to
analyze the expression specifically in
the TDP 43 deleted oligodendrocytes and
icw helped them to accomplish that
now let's dig a little deeper into the
actual workflow next and what you need
to incorporate this assay into your
research
here you can see what reagents are
required to use this workflow for the
leico auto staining platform so there is
somewhat of a different reagents
necessary for the manual icw platform
but today I'm just going to focus on the
Leica automated system
so included in this icw kit is a
co-detection antibody diluin
specifically developed for the icw
workflow as you can see many common
antibody dilutants and blocking reagents
contain ingredients that can negatively
impact RNA scope we see a lot of loss of
ppib signal in this middle image because
of the composition of the antibody
dilute sold by Leica it's important to
dilute all antibodies in this diluent
for the icw procedures that includes
your primary and your secondary
antibodies
the typical blocking steps included
before primary incubation of antibody in
traditional IHC or if protocols should
also be avoided when using icw
here is a table that summarizes exactly
what you need using the
Leica assay on the right in the manual
which I'm not going to talk about much
on the left the only important thing to
note here is that the Leica assays they
all still use the er2 as a Target
retrieval and they also use the Leica
code detection blocker so really all you
need to run this aside from some other
nuances regarding the protease that I'll
talk about in a bit is the code
detection antibody diluent
of course in addition to the icw reagent
kit you're also going to need a bond RX
to run this automated assay
you'll also need your chosen detection
kit so this could be RNA scope base
scope micro RNA scope
you'll also need your your probes
including your target probe your RNA
Target your positive and negative
control probes it's important to note
that if you're running more than one
plexing so two to three rnas your C2 and
C3 probes which are specific to your
channel 2 RNA and your channel 3 RNA
will actually be 50x and they'll be
diluted directly into your C1 probe if
you don't want to use a C1 probe you can
also dilute them directly into probe
diluent finally you will need ACD
control slides which are used to ensure
that the assay is running correctly on
your machine
other items that are required from Leica
are these Bond open containers so this
is what we transfer our ACD reagents
into in order to run on the machine
including all the amplification steps
you'll need Bond Wash Fond d-wax
epitope retrieval for Target retrieval
and of course your mixing station your
bond detection kits and cover tiles to
run the assay
finally after the essay is run you're
going to need reagents in order to
dehydrate depending on the the exact
detection system you're using so please
refer to your manual for example with
fast red chromogene we're not going to
use any ethanol because it's very
sensitive to ethanol and it would ruin
the signal
finally the antibodies and secondary
antibodies that you use
are not sold by ACD so these are
antibodies that are used in other
traditional ish traditional IHC or amino
fluorescent
situations that are compatible also with
icw
I also just want to focus on the TSA
Vivid dies so these are fluorophores
that are required for the multiplex
fluorescent detection these are sold by
ACD and they are compatible with icw
while preparing samples it is important
to note that each sample type has a
varying sample preparation storage and
sectioning guidelines so RNA scope and
icw is compatible with both formal
infects formal and fixed paraffin
embedded tissues fixed Frozen tissues
and fresh frozen tissues for ffpe ACD
recommends samples be fixed in 10 NBF
for 16 to 32 hours at room temp
samples are recommended to be stored at
4C for long-term storage with desiccants
and be sections from four to six microns
for fixed rows and samples are
recommended to be fixed for 24 hours at
4C with either four percent PFA or 10
formulin and for fresh frozen samples
are recommended to be frozen immediately
after harvest
both fixed and fresh frozen samples
should be stored at minus 80 Celsius for
up to three months in an airtight
container
fix Frozen samples are recommended to be
sectioned at 7 to 15 microns at 10 to 20
microns for fresh frozen samples
so this is an overview of the first
portion of the workflow for the
chromogenic assays in ffpe paraffin
samples
please keep in mind that the fresh
frozen and fixed Frozen samples will
need to be treated with slightly
different conditions but both are
compatible with the icw kit I also want
to note that it is important to optimize
both the ish and IHC procedures
separately for any sample type before
combining them in this way this
minimizes additional Downstream
Downstream troubleshooting but it is
common that some optimization will be
needed when combining the assays
we begin with the sample preparation I
mentioned on the previous slide followed
by hydrogen peroxide pre-treatment and
the co-detection target retrieval
after Target retrieval we had the
primary antibody
then complete the post primary fixation
now we can move on to the appropriate
protease for our tissue
and move on to hybrid days our RNA scope
face scope or micro RNA scope Pro
after the amplification steps have been
completed and the ish signal is
developed with the fast red chromogen
the peroxide block step is performed to
prevent cross detection between the two
chemistries the protein signal is then
developed using dab or green chromogen
after incubation with an hrp conjugated
secondary antibody
as a reminder both the primary and the
secondary antibody should be diluted in
the co-detection antibody diluent
for RNA scope you have six amplification
steps to build the amplification trees
and then alkaline phosphatase and fast
red chromogen will be used for Signal
detection of the C1 or channel one
target
you can also see an example of this
staining on the right with cd19 in brown
and ppib in red ppiv is the ish so this
is your RNA Target and cd19 is the
protein
okay
now the base scope assay single Plex is
similar but instead of using six
amplification steps it uses eight
amplification steps to build the
amplification tree the reason is pretty
logical it's because you're targeting a
smaller RNA transcript so you need more
amplification in order to see signal now
between the base scope and the RNA scope
kits the chemistry is slightly different
the amps have different temperatures and
durations so it's important that you
follow the steps accurately for
whichever assay you're using
the base scope single Plex assay also
uses Alp fast red chemistry for
detection of a C1 or channel one target
but base scope and RNA scope probes are
not interchangeable one is much smaller
base scope and one is much longer so if
you tried to combine the two they will
not work
thank you
again the Mi RNA scope micro RNA scope
single Plex red chromogenic assay will
follow a similar procedure to the RNA
scope single Plex red assay but there's
an additional fixation step that must be
incorporated when preparing your samples
additionally micro RNA scope probes have
a unique design that is different than
RN is filth and base scope so these Pros
are probes are designated by an S1 in
their name and the micro RNA scope probe
must be used with a micro RNA scope
detection kit so here you can see Mir
2233p which is in red and you can see
CD3 stained in green which is your
protein stain and this is a cervical
cancer tissue
next let's look at the amplification and
detection for our fluorescent assays
here amp 1 amp2 and amp3 build the
amplification trees for multiple
channels at the same time
this is followed by sequential detection
of each Target
here we have the the detection of three
different channels this is just a
visualization of what it looks like so
the amplification trees will hybridize
on each Channel at the same time in
addition the amplification branches will
hybridize onto these preamplification
trees all at the same time and then we
go through and we sequentially
deposit a fluorophore onto each Channel
individually
this requires The Binding of hrpc1 to
the C1 amplification tree and then the
addition of a vivid die the Vivid dies
will react with the hrpc reagents to
become active and deposit of fluorophore
hrp blocker is then used to block
hrpc1 and end the detection process for
this channel
next we repeat the series for the C2
tree and the C3 tree
either Vivid dice or opal fluorophores
are are required to be purchased for
this procedure and Vivid dice can be
purchased directly from Advanced cell
Diagnostics
this is nice because the assay has some
flexibility as any Vivid die can be
assigned to any channel or any antibody
the vividi concentration can also be
optimized allowing for the ability to
control the intensity of the staining
there are additional Vivid dies
available that fluoresce different
wavelengths as well which I will show
later they can all be used with this
workflow in any channel
next we have the workflow for ish Amino
fluorescence co-detection
the concept is very similar to that of
the chroma genetic icw I just showed you
in which an antibody is added after the
pre-treatment steps and fixed using 10
NBF then the RNA scope Multiplex
fluorescent portion of the protocol is
completed finally we need to label the
antibody with a secondary fluorescent
and now there are two ways that you can
do this option one is to use an hrp
conjugated secondary antibody and a
tsa-based 404 reagent similar to the
Vivid dice that we've been using
throughout the rest of the assay
and option 2 employs a fluorophore
conjugated secondary antibody to
visualize Amino fluorescence signal
either workflow can be used and the
selection will depend on your preferred
secondary antibodies
here's an example image of the staining
that can be achieved with Multiplex
fluorescent V2 and the icw kit
so here's showing Ki 67 which is the
protein in the stain with our positive
control probes for the RNA expression
pole r2a ppib and UBC and you can see
that the result is this very stunning
beautiful image that shows single cell
RNA transcription along with protein
marker ki-67
all right
here are a few General tips for success
with the icw kit as I mentioned we
recommend establishing ish and amino
histochemistry or immunofluorescence
protocols for your samples and
antibodies separately before attempting
to combine them
we also know that many researchers
include a blocking step before adding
their antibodies and if you would like
to do this before either your primary or
secondary antibodies we recommend using
the co-detection antibody dilute in
place of your standard blocking reagents
our diluent includes components that can
help prevent non-specific binding
and I didn't really talk about this
because we're not talking manual in this
presentation but if you are doing the
manual assay we recommend using the
overnight primary antibody incubation as
the breakpoint of the assay but this
does give bring up a good point that the
benefit of having the Leica automated
system is that it's a machine so it
doesn't get tired you can run the assay
overnight come in the next morning and
cover slip and you're good to go
when you're first implementing the icw
assay we recommend including test slides
with the primary antibody at the same
concentration that was used in IHC and
at a concentration that is five hold
five fold higher we have seen that at
times it's necessary to use two to five
the ITC antibody concentration for icw
the antibody incubation time and
temperature should remain the same but I
would say if you're starting this off
right off the bat just try five times
your antibody dose because often it does
require that much
then we have a couple other
recommendations for the first time you
are running the Leica
icw protocol using the Leica platform
first you should double the hidr
incubation time from what it was optimal
for ish only but at the same temperature
so typically I think we recommend 15
minutes of Target retrieval and so
doubling it would be 30 minutes and
secondly we recommend using a protease
time of 30 minutes
one final thing to say about the
protease is that different kits and
different tissue types require different
proteases so either Proteus plus
protease 3 and protease floor for
example base scope icw requires
protease4 but base scope ish only
requires protease 3 so just make sure
you read your manual carefully
before you perform the assay
now I'm going to go over some Imaging
and Analysis
when analyzing RNA scope signal it is
important to know that the signal
appears as numerous punctuate dots of
various sizes and intensities and many
clusters of dots may also be present
depending on RNA expression
it is the number of dots and or clusters
that are important rather than the size
of the dot or the intensity of the top
each punctate dot as represented by the
yellow and pink arrows represents one
mRNA molecule the slightly larger
punctate dots shown by this Pink Arrow
is also one RNA molecule however it is
larger in size as more of the ZZ probes
have found to the Target molecule so
what this is assuming is that this RNA
transcript although it represents one
RNA transcript was more heavily degraded
excuse me and so therefore
less ZZ probes hybridized to this
transcript then this RNA transcript
which is the same exact transcript but
it was slightly better preserved so more
ZZ probes hybridized to it and therefore
you have a larger Dot
in contrast this blue arrow shows a
cluster
so this is kind of an oblong slightly
irregular shape and is the result of
overlapping signals from multiple RNA
copies
foreign
now some challenges in analyzing
chromogenic images there are several
things in tissue that can lead to false
chromogenic signal the images on the
left are good clean negative and
positive images so you're adapting
negative control has nice morphology no
background your PPI positive control has
lots of functate dots and good
morphology
we recommend that you always include
negative and positive controls as they
provide a point of reference
the images on the right are
representative images that may give a
false signal the first is an image with
a pink case that is inherent to the
tissue which may appear similar to the
color in our red assays
but in a high quality image as seen on
the far right we are able to distinguish
the colors between this pink Haze and
the red signal based on their intensity
this is common in tissues such as kidney
that have high endogenous alkaline
phosphatase activity
there are other structures and tissues
that may have colors for example here
tar lipofucin and melanin they are
easily distinguishable from red color
but they might be more difficult to
separate from the brown signal if you're
using dab for IHC
after selecting the appropriate setup
for your experiment let's look at the
workflow for Imaging
first we recommend using the dappy
channel to find a good Focus plane next
go through each channel for the positive
control slide and find the appropriate
exposure time
this depends on your system as discussed
in the previous slide but should be less
than a few hundred milliseconds with a
good setup
now you should go to the negative
control slide using these exposure times
to check for any background
lower the exposure time as much as
necessary to eliminate the background
we recommend acquiring images at 40x
magnification or higher for analysis
for this reason it's very important to
always use these positive and negative
controls to determine what is true
fluorescent signal another tip is to
only expose the sample to light while
looking at it or acquiring an image
similar to all Amino fluorescence
extended exposure will result in
quenching of the fluorescent signal over
time
and finally we want to adjust exposure
to maximize the dynamic range for each
image without over exposing any pixels
foreign
here are a few suggestions for dealing
with challenging autofluorescent tissues
as I mentioned we recommend always
running positive and negative controls
to provide a comparison the green
Channel tends to have the most Auto
fluorescence because it has the lowest
signal to noise ratio so it is helpful
to assign the highest expressing Target
here
this way the signal is more likely to be
visible against the autofluorescent
background
if you have access to a multi-spectral
Imaging system and software this can
help subtract the background by
identifying broad emission Spectra that
are common for autofluorescence
finally when working with highly
autofluorescent tissues you may need to
adjust the fluorophore concentrations to
adjust the signal to noise ratio
if you have any questions and need any
help you can always contact support at
support.acd at biotechnie.com
when it comes to image analysis we
recommend using image J otherwise known
as Fiji qpath or cell profiler some
researchers also use Halo software to
analyze RNA spoke images we have an RNA
scope data analysis guide available
online as well as multiple recorded
webinars that discuss analysis on these
different platforms
so to add a quick summary our icw kit
and procedures enable multi-amic
profiling of tissues with single cell
resolution and spatial context this
allows us to answer complex biological
questions while also preserving precious
samples these are reagents are available
to be automated on the Leica plot
platform including our RNA scope base
scope and micro RNA code detection and
finally multi-flex fluorescent V2 assays
I want to thank you for joining us today
for joining me
before answering a few questions I want
to highlight our previous recorded
webinars on our website on acd's website
and I have some contact information here
in case you'd like to reach out to
technical support or visit our website
and contact sales we're always happy to
help you with your research however we
can
I want to thank you for listening and I
also want to thank the Leica team for
having me and I'm available to answer
any questions you might have
all right well thank you Blake for your
informative presentation now before we
start our live q a session I want to
draw your attention to the resource box
on your screen here you can find
additional brochures web pages and
videos related to today's presentation
all right so now let's get started with
our live q a portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right
so our first question here asks does er1
interfere with the ish detection
okay that's a good question so does er1
interfere with the ish so the RNA scope
uh portion of the icw assay
um the answer is yes it does so er1 is a
citrate-based retrieval solution with a
pH of six whereas er2 is EDTA based with
a pH of nine and we've optimized the RNA
scope protocol to be compatible with er2
so er2 is what works best it's what
we've tested in-house and what we
suggest everyone use
er1 would it work perhaps but I would
suggest trying that because it's already
been optimized for er2 so uh yes please
use er2 and
don't
you could try to use the R1 but I
wouldn't recommend it
great thank you I have another question
here in regards to er2 this question
asks can you interchange er2 for other
retrieval types such as the R1 or pro-k
yeah so that's a very similar question
uh using a protein proteinase K Target
retrieval versus er1 again
we recommended we've optimized the
protocol to be compatible with er2 only
so I would highly suggest trying it with
er2 seeing if your antibody is also
compatible and going from there
great thank you another question we have
here doesn't the protease affect the
primary antibody that will already be on
the slide
yeah so that's kind of the whole purpose
of icw so the idea is that when you
combine RNA scope with ish there's two
ways of doing it one is a sequential
stain where you do the ish and then you
do the IFC and in the ish there's a
protease step so the idea is that if you
try a sequential stain and it doesn't
work it's likely because the protease is
degrading the antigen binding site for
the antibody so the icw is different in
that we we do a post fixation step after
adding the primary antibody so this post
fixation step should preserve hopefully
preserve this epitope binding between
the antibody and the antigen and protect
it from the protease degradation
so the protease will still affect the
antibody likely but that's why we've
developed this icw Proto protocol in
hopes that it preserves the antigen
antibody binding more so than if we
didn't have this post-fixation step
Thank You Blake got another question
here that's asking for Mirna scope and
base scope assays could we use another
chromogen other than fast red
so for mRNA scope and base scope the
fast red chromogen is is the only one
available for the RNA scope portion of
the assay so it would be fast red RNA
scope and then the green is for protein
because fast red is alkaline phosphatase
and that's the technology that we've
developed that's compatible with RNA
scope on the Leica Bond so it does need
to be fast read for the ish portion of
that icw assay
great next question asks is the green
chromogen provided by Leica
yeah so there's actually two chromogens
that we uh have used with the icw assay
historically we've used the ACD green
which is sold by ACD however that's not
fully automated so you have to do the
Ice the ish portion you have to actually
go offline so for the icw assay if
you're combining RNA scope with protein
Leica green is the the green chromogen
that we use so it is provided by Leica
and it's fully automated
great thank you
this question is asking whether protein
Mi RNA interaction can be analyzed
uh yes yeah so that's kind of
the purpose of this protocol
um if you're trying to
[Music]
spatially evaluate micro RNA scope
expression with a protein or to look at
South specific expressions of micro rnas
of micro RNA expression you can do that
with the icw assay so um yes the the the
uh
the the interaction between those
proteins and mRNA can be analyzed and
that's kind of why this has been
developed
great thanks Blake we're getting such
great questions in from our audience
here we're getting so many so we're
going to keep going here the next
question that I have for you is can the
chromogenic signal from the protein
detection part of the code detection
assay be used to identify fold increases
and protein concentration
okay yeah so that's kind of it it
depends right depends on your protein
and your protein concentration if you
have a protein that's already completely
saturated then uh if you have
so if you can look at full changes in
your protein concentration without icw
without RNA scope then you can do it
with RNA scope so if you're using a
protein stain to evaluate changes in
protein expression in a tissue alone
then it's also going to be possible to
do that using RNA scope and combining
the two so it depends on your protein
how large the expression is and if you
can actually quantify the difference in
expression based on the protein alone
great next question have you compared
fluorescent with chromogenic routes to
see if the signal is comparable for the
same transcript
[Music]
the signal should be comparable yeah
um
that there is a slide somewhere I I
didn't present it here today but
um
if the protein stain is the same so it's
still the same amount of antibody
binding it's just the way that you
visualize it so uh yes the the
fluorescent and chromogenic protein
signal is comparable
great
next question what are all the possible
controls should we use while trying to
detect protein Mi RNA interactions
so with each kit we suggest running
every time you run RNA scope we suggest
running it with positive and negative
controls to ensure that the staining is
running accurately so uh with the the
kit there is a negative micro RNA probe
which is just a scrambled probe and then
there's a positive micro RNA scope probe
which is expressed by all tissues so
um to answer that question we do suggest
using controls and we have them and we
sell them and they're they're provided
with the kit depending on which
formulation of the kit you actually
purchase
all right and we've got time for just a
few more questions here so this next one
asks are there plans to create a
fluorescent Multiplex kit for Mi RNA
scope
that's a good question so we actually
just came out with a new kit which is
called RNA scope plus it's not something
that we have much experience combining
with icw with protein stains yet but I
do know people are trying that so it's
not an MI RNA scope
fluorescent kit specifically so it's not
combining multiple Mirna scope micro RNA
targets but it's actually combining one
micro RNA Target along with up to three
RNA targets so you can Target one very
small trench one very small genetic
uh RNA transcript and then you can
Target up to three larger so 300 to a
thousand nucleotide RNA trick lengths
transcripts simultaneously using
fluorescent
so in a way we have just released uh
Multiplex fluorescent for small rnas
combined with rnas
great thank you this next question asks
I am interested in how the bond RX
reduces a lab's Hands-On time can you
expand on this from your experience and
just this use of automation help with
variability in Downstream results
yeah definitely so if you're doing if
you have experience with RNA scope you
know that if you're doing RNA scope
Multiplex fluorescent or even RNA scope
chromogenic manually it's advised to
split the assay up over two days because
the whole thing is going to be around 10
to 12 hours so if you're doing it
manually it usually takes two days to
complete the assay whereas when you have
a Leica Bond you can program the machine
at night press play and then you can
just run it overnight you don't even
have to think about it so once you have
everything set up on the machine which
is my job so I the the field application
scientists would come in help set up the
assays and then you just run them
overnight you don't think about it and
when you get there the next day it's
done so on the machine it also takes
around 10 hours that there's no that's
not Hands-On time that's hands-off time
so it does really reduce the amount of
time it takes to run this assay and the
second one was about variability yeah so
of course if you're automating something
and you're not inducing human error it
definitely improves it reduces the
amount of variability that you see
compared to manual because you know it's
always going to be the same every time
as long as there's nothing wrong with
the machine your variability should be
much lower
wonderful well Blake we're going to go
ahead and wrap up with one more question
here so this question asks I don't know
if I understood this correctly but is it
possible to measure protein IHC plus RNA
in the same sample or slide for code
detection
yes absolutely that's the purpose of the
this this protocol integrated code
detection workflow so you're evaluating
you're doing a protein stain and
combining that with an RNA scope state
so you're looking at both protein and
RNA expression on the same slide same
tissue even within the same cell
so that that's what this technology is
for and that's why it was developed
right well as I mentioned we're going to
go ahead and wrap things up up here so
Blake I want to thank you again for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank Lab Rats and
our sponsor Leica bio systems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you had provided at
the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye